[Music]
many of our colleagues at cnn are hoping
this new week plays out much better than
the last
the past several days have been
difficult for the network
fox news media analyst and host of fox's
media buzz howard kurtz
shows us tonight it's been a week of
setbacks for cnn the network dumped
longtime contributor rick santorum
one of its few conservative voices over
the weekend after the former senator
insulted an entire community
there's nothing here i mean yes we have
native americans but
but candidly that that there isn't much
native american culture in american
culture
after an outcry santorum tried to do
damage control on chris cuomo's show
but refused to apologize i misspoke in
this respect i was talking about the
founding
and the principles embodied in the
founding santorum now says he knew he'd
be providing commentary that is not
regularly heard
by the typical cnn viewer cuomo for his
part is still
dealing with the fallout from privately
advising his brother andrew cuomo
on dealing with sexual harassment
allegations by joining conference calls
that included the new york governor's
top aides
and advisors that led to a prime time
apology
i understand why that was a problem for
cnn it will not happen again
it was a mistake i think he made a huge
mistake by being on that call i mean
it's just you just don't want to be part
of the official apparatus of the
governor of new york's office
cnn called cuomo's actions inappropriate
but has resisted calls to punish him
the network also cut ties with middle
east freelancer adil raja
for tweeting to his 80 000 followers
that the world needs another hitler
and calling the israelis terrorists
seven years after making
similar pro-hitler comments cnn called
those statements
abhorrent all this taking place as cnn
is getting yet another corporate owner
three years after being bought by a t
the network will join a unit newly
merged
with discovery chris cuomo's apology at
least enables him and his bosses to move
on
santara's refusal ends his four-year run
at the network this means cnn which has
lost other conservative contributors to
various controversies
now has one less prominent republican
voice
brett howie governor cuomo was asked
about his brother today what do you tell
reporters
well brett governor cuomo said chris is
my best friend i don't always follow his
advice and then he said this
i talk to journalists about situations
all the time and they tell me their
thoughts
and offer their advice now i don't know
what other unnamed journalists say in
schmoozing cuomo
but they're not related to him and
secondly they're not participating in
damage control strategy sessions with
the democratic governor
and his top staff so that seemed like a
pretty obvious deflection
delivered with brotherly love brett
seems a little different
howie thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else